[Music]
let's talk about another viral tick-tock
okay
tic TOCs all over the news today Jeff
can we just do a whole dance tic TOCs we
actually can cuz the news just only
wants to cover oh you wanted a little
tic toc challenge right there that's
cool
the news only wants to cover tic toc can
I stop your titties on tick tock okay
yeah do it there's no way you could get
the montage on tick tock cuz you can
monetize yet
that's facts but see that's why right
now account taken down and the algorithm
doesn't [ __ ] you on tick tock so you can
like the these are what they are well it
is very much the Wild West it's like cuz
you never know it's gonna hit that page
and pop off Wow
but they pop like hard dude they're
going 35 million oh my god like one
video get a thousand views and all of a
sudden the next one
you got piggies well just because of the
way your hands are moving sometimes
that's a whole country pretty crazy okay
we get it
I think we get this medium I think we
cracked it there was this Wendy's
employee from Michigan who filmed
himself at work they still got the who's
taking a bath that dirtiest [ __ ] but
that in a bathroom how does he fit he's
tiny
now that's a big suit the powers
so this is his last week right he's like
[ __ ] is it that is a big you know
they've been doing [ __ ] like this before
cameras I wish you just screaming at the
camera give me views no I guess that's
what it looks like yeah how do they know
as Wendy's because of the uniform so
this is a kid you got fired up you got
viral
I almost said viral and fired together
yes I would fire you know it's exact is
the first social media platform that
really made me feel like I'm too old to
engage I can't
but there's older people than you on
them yeah and that's that makes me feel
sad for them no but - I follow this old
Asian man who does all the new dances oh
he's so cute
his head soo is like shoulder ratio
[ __ ] freaks me out this is it yeah
it's heads huge and his like shoulders
are narrow so I'm like is it like is it
like computer or is it the guy in Japan
that does all the modern movies yes it's
so good
watch now look at his shoulder at the
head ratio great now I'm not gonna be
able to not see it I think it's the
standard asian man the q-tip body he
dips more heads no I hit I say yeah
great shoulders stupid I have a bigger
head than all you well know I'm seeing
the head to shoulder but you also you
know it looks more proportionate on your
body I feel I have like a small body and
like I like a really round you look fine
yeah but if I'm sitting down which I
always am on Jake he knows I think it
looks [ __ ] nuts
goddamn overwhelming well you know
what's fun job is like overwhelming
I always see the clip am I hit so I
leave forward to when I do this [ __ ] and
then tips head it's like really small
minds
yeah so people always like is Tim's head
really huge or is 2/10 really small
that's very flattering at you this is
the best size this is a [ __ ] car look
here I look pretty nuts okay oh I know
I'm gonna do something you like Brad
Pitt oh my god over here Steve's face
looks like the troll guy face dude I'm
[ __ ] huge over here that's crazy
oh I know I'm not even going to make it
today Paul mere tick tock tick tock
I'm the almost tock tick tock double
jugular yeah no makeup no missing my
mark on tick-tock so I gotta wait til
the next platform to jump on that you
could jump on it now what are you
talking about
I finally try to sign up there's
probably already gonna be Bar Cornwall
bark 1 2 or 3 or 4 I thought be got bars
1 300 flights and no one took your name
I know I just got mark 1 this is easy
you want to buy it I got it right away
I'll give you free 215 jeez you guys I
never bite is that the new one bite is
the new vine is it is it getting more
Mak out of whatsapp do you think that
bark wan 1 2 5 they just do workout
videos like to post my work on do you
post anything at all yeah yeah I just
put fum well I first of all I scroll
through my phone and anything that was
long ways I put up just like literally
anything I had that was long as I could
let's throw that up there no I don't do
[ __ ] I'm you're such a responsible
influencer social media person you know
I just um he cares about his career
whoa no not a sec err my career
necessarily care about my I see tick
tock as just um a potential other like
way to make money I see that too but I'm
not responsible enough to do it timmy is
it only five seconds of video up to a
minute oh so you know here's it longer
no it's it's up to a minute and here's
the thing to that that when I had my
little tick tock meeting the girls
me a lot of things are actually kind of
pop in or just people ranting it's like
a minute really yeah which is why I felt
like that I said another take a video it
feels like YouTube like early YouTube
turn the camera on and and rant about
something X and sure the bubble thingy
and then they're all dancing and I'm
like I'm not like that I could talk [ __ ]
and dance do you see what that looks
like your mama
[ __ ] your mama that's a song yeah if
there's a catchy one though that
probably would do pretty well
oh and there's gonna remix it don't be
so late you just uh [ __ ] your mama your
mama uh uh [ __ ] your mama I don't know I
see everyone do it no part of me is like
I want to try it but I'm like no you're
gonna try it try it
no [ __ ] your mama he's like he was that
he is doing it I'm like no but doesn't
Isaac think it's lame he was like you're
on tick-tock real keep saw no when he
first saw the tick-tock app on my phone
he was like mom this is so grand you
have it on your phone and now he he
loved photography oh so you got him in
know you thought that I guess it is
school it's like oh if you tick tock
you're lame really yeah but now it's
it's like the norm it's kind of
unescapable man yeah like that's what
I'm saying I'm not like I thought this
is gonna go away like musically I was
hoping was gonna go away dude when Power
Rangers came out I was I was tell all
the kids when that joke came out I was
call him all kinds of names that you
can't say that but no cause like when
Power Rangers came out I was like this
shit's whack like you [ __ ] suck you
watch this Power Rangers [ __ ] right and
then I just completely lost the war
like everyone watching Power Rangers and
then you just start watching Power
Rangers too
and then you just as one Halloween huh I
was gonna say it's okay did you see the
trailers now for it for Power Rangers
you mean the original Power Rangers
remember like watching it so I never
caught the show right I only had seen
the trailers and I was like this
whack-ass you judged it before you watch
yeah [ __ ] you're constantly I never
judge stuff off the trailer man oh
that's how I think that's how America is
I think we I think we judge ever had
some trailers
the cover of the book didn't even read
the article they just read the headline
the true you know what I heard I heard
that Sonic the Hedgehog movies actually
good well I want to see it really I
really want it I watch it if they don't
change his [ __ ] teeth dude i watch
the trailer I was like this looks like
hot ass right but now I apparently
everyone say well I don't judge movies
by the trailers because one of my
favorite comedies is on his hot rod and
hot rod is with the lonely island guy I
heard it was really [ __ ] good so
funny and like a really weird like out
there way and the trailer was trashed
though the trailer makes it look so
stupid I was like this is wack right
then but the homies took me in so it's
the one my favorite like just silly
comedy you know what's another movies
good you ever watch walk hard yeah have
you seen macGruber oh I heard macGruber
is amazing one of my favorite movies
that whoever looks so stupid and
funniest [ __ ] move yeah it's so
goddamn funny so Netflix I don't think
so I don't even know that movie it's
funny we should all watch it's very fun
there's no gang here's a dude what is it
it's based off an SNL skit it's that one
do you
yeah [ __ ] yeah yeah no Will Forte
Forte yes oh it's like the parody of
MacGyver Oh Magoo bears what is really I
mean the movie is not even that they
just [ __ ] clown on all kinds of [ __ ]
it's great it's really how come there's
no good parody movies anymore
we were just talking about that me and
Bart were but the naked guy like a phase
like movie industry and phases and then
like that one's already past well I
think the problem is that so there's a
very funny parody movie came out a
couple years ago Andy Samberg did that
to the [ __ ] pop silence oh I heard
that super funny super funny never but
it bombed at the box office bomb so [ __ ]
like that I guess it scares the appetite
of the audience or they just didn't do a
good job marketing it I think probably
that the marketing part any people are
so they're so night nowadays they find
everything so like corny like if it's
not a really kind of dry humor now
people like ah this is corny you know
I'm saying if it's like people don't
like to do slapstick stuff anymore they
feel like it's kind of I thought it just
went on Instagram
hmm people that like slapstick it just
went on Instagram
yeah that's one saying that's what I
feel like but like when they watch it in
movies even when I do like
like corny skits where you know I
exaggerate certain things people now is
like I do this is this is like mrs.
Corney and I thought on Instagram it's
like oh this is hilarious it's just the
age range of who's watching where but
sometimes I can feel like when you do
the really corny [ __ ] when it's obvious
that it's corny on purpose and you're
making silly jokes on purpose then it's
it's clever because it's so corny
you know I'm saying but people get like
pods and [ __ ] yeah cuz you know it's
supposed to be shitty yeah puns are
supposed to be good jokes well let's not
go there you know it's just you know is
just a fun game right boy yeah I know
the bit you love I don't love them I
love my wife hated that you don't like
them and I draw the line after that but
I think the thing with comedy it's it's
got to be truthful right or that group
but then now we're more I think it's
more disconnected because there's more
subcultures when we were growing up it
was like one [ __ ] media thing so like
everyone got that movie because everyone
watched Rambo hmm so then it's like if
you watch that or whatever then if
action movie comes out everyone gets the
joke but now that's why I think meme
culture and like all that [ __ ] or like
trolling is funny because within that
group you get it and then you have a
whole other bunch of people that are
getting fooled but yeah and then there's
there's such a thing too where people
try to go like whole wall you know I
only don't want to get my laugh smartly
or whatever but it's those pretentious
[ __ ] right
mass laughs and laughs and laughs like
if if you've got somebody laugh on
tik-tok like it's the same to me as
getting somebody left on the smarter I
like slapstick because it's the comedies
Universal you don't have to have like
any pre-existing knowledge it's just
funny to see like Charlie Chaplin or
like to be Stooges type stuff and just
you just get it this yeah and I respect
all the forms even though I only like a
certain type of comedy usually like a
couple types like but I still respect
all of it because you have to
if the respect what it does to people I
hope you all forms of comedy too that's
what seeing like whatever people like oh
man this is low-hanging fruit I'm like
low-hanging fruit is delicious too
Timothy DeLaGhetto low-hanging fruit is
my brand my bill now oh [ __ ] babe
but people like especially when I grew
up watch like I loved Seinfeld people
say cycles like you know likes it's too
dry or whatever but and also ah but I
also grew up I loved family matters to
eat I'm saying we're [ __ ] Steve Urkel
was falling all over the place and you
know talking in silly voice he never saw
a piece of furniture he didn't run into
that was awesome
[Music]
[Music]